what up guys welcome to just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to kevin
samuels you tell women like me we don't
deserve
marriage before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos while you're
at it go follow my instagram
it is just pearly things but instead of
the s
at the end you're gonna put a z okay
and what you're saying um
about where we are today and what are
our plans to prepare for winter is
coming
um and just kind of give you a
background of what i have going on
and to figure out am i on the right path
to prepare for the winner
do you what do you want as an outcome
for your life
regarding social a man
a man i want a partnership um
that does that mean
what i'm gonna need you ladies to start
doing is stop calling
i wanted you to stop diminishing
marriage into partnerships
and calling it marriage you're going to
partnership with businesses
just start calling i'm just saying not
to you but i think we diminish
these titles so much just like when i
see people calling themselves
ceos solo uh
social pride issue you're not a goddamn
ceo
well i was thinking that marriage was a
partnership i mean
i i mean i get understanding but that's
the problem it's not okay
but by calling him okay
so when you're married do you mind if he
calls you his
old lady this chick no no not once we
get to the point of marriage want to be
called a wife
yes sir oh okay so you that title man
that title mary's
matters oh you do understand the deal
i do thanks that's all i'm trying to say
but you want to be married that's all
i'm trying to get you see the fact that
we got to do that
let me just say this black people we
need to over
perform in formality
and respect we are far too informal with
each other
right so you want a you want a marriage
and a husband what else would you like
um in terms of
out of the marriage
big picture what do you want because you
because mostly
okay i just want to understand what the
outcome is you a marriage
do you want children yes i actually have
three kevin
uh have you been married before no sir
why have you chosen not to marry any of
the fathers of your children
um well i have a 20 year old and i have
18 year old
why are you chosen not to marry the
father of any of your children
okay this is what baffles me there is so
many forms of birth control
like you can be completely not careful
and you could still get a plan b
like to marriage with my first child
my first two kids fathers was close to
marriage
we were um entertaining the idea we were
both open
to it we already had children
we had children together did he want to
marry you
yes he did so i don't see now it's about
to get hard i don't i
hate it when you ladies come in and do
this [ __ ]
you already had two human beings
yeah you talk about entertaining
marriage
you should have entertained marriage
before you entertained motherhood
right well we learn we're learning
do it can i grow it can i learn well
unfortunately yes but it may be too late
because if you're still talking about
marriage as a partnership
and if 37 years old you're still using
words like i would expect a young girl
to use like
i entertain marriage instead of saying i
want a husband
i want to be a husband i want to be a
wife i want additional kids
and i have three children by two
different men and i blew those
relationships because
i wasn't woman enough to walk down the
aisle
that's what men really want to hear from
y'all okay and this [ __ ] they'll
come to you
and you know what kevin um i i really
saw myself so much in
when you um stated that
we our culture of women are are
scared you know operating in fear
and i think that's what has been my
problem because
marriage has not been a hard thing for
me if
how is your youngest child he's eight
why did you okay so he was almost 30
when you had that child why didn't you
marry his father
that was more so of something that just
kind of moved
fast um i don't know you know you know
good and damn well i'm not going to
accept that
i was even coming why would you even
come at me with it move fast what did i
ask
why why didn't he ask her to be
accountable and she's still not doing it
saying like i'm i messed up i made the
mistake
get married right
i wasn't interested in a marriage with
him kevin why were you interested in
having this baby
she's looking dead at me kevin
she needs to know the truth so she
doesn't do this too
she's definitely not gonna do this no
i'm talking to you
you were not interested in marrying him
but you why'd you have his faith
because it happened it didn't happen
ma'am you were 30 years old having
unprotected sex you already had two
children
you more than any other woman on the
planet knows the outcome
right now why am i being this dip hard
because you talking about you want a
husband or you're looking for a
step-father
any man who will marry you will be a
stepfather and a woman like you
who can't take accountability
i haven't taken accountability no you
haven't in this conversation
it just happened no you just said it
just happened no she's not she's giving
excuse after excuse after excuse
i know plenty of girls
that dated guys for years and did not
get pregnant
okay ma'am maybe that okay maybe to you
that's taking accountability
okay what what could i have said that
made it sound like accountability to you
uh i was still more willing to be a
mother than a wife so i was having
unprotected sex with a man who's not a
husband
okay well i apologize for not working
i'm just saying that's the truth
why was he good with my wife's but my
thing is why have unprotected sex with a
man
like that if you want if you don't have
sex with him have sex with him but why
reproduce with it
because if it happens what am i saying
it didn't just happen
we had sex i got pregnant and i made the
decision like you just said
to go ahead and be a mother to somebody
that i knew
was not a potential husband and i made a
mistake
so we are here today but she made a
choice that's not a mistake that's a
choice
and that's that's that's the language
that i think kevin gets really
frustrated with
and i'm trusting your expertise to
listen
and learn man
it didn't just happen
it didn't just happen you're a mother of
two children three you were a mother of
two before you got pregnant with this
child
you were in a sexual relationship
with a man who was not of the caliber of
man he would become a
wife for true or false
true or false true then
you choosing to have unprotected
sex with that man did not
just happen that was a
choice every time you speak
every time you lay every time whatever
position you guys chose
unprotected sex how can so many other
women on the planet choose to have sex
with some of the
worst of the worst men and not walk away
with a baby
because they choose to get contraception
they choose to not have babies with men
33 forms of birth control available to
30 year old women
it did not just happen i'm pretty sure
you can get condoms for
free at like clinics and stuff
any man that you will be talking about
you want to learn from he's listening to
this and i would say
brother what are you trying to say to
this man you'll be like
you're not taking any accountability it
just happened it just happened
well maybe i didn't work that correctly
but i have no problem with taking
accountability
okay all right so i apologize for not
let's move forward let's move let's move
let's number four take accountability
let's move forward let's
how about this thing how about this
do you want to get married now
because i feel like um
that's something that i deserve to
experience that's something i i
feel like i have value to brains who are
black men in the community
um i feel like i have a lot to offer
despite the mistakes that i had made and
that is why
i am here you know willing to have this
conversation with you because
a lot of times some of the things that i
have been through
you you mark us out for that
and i don't feel like that it's fair or
true whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
a lot of things that i mark you out for
like in general i don't mark you out for
anything
well a lot of times you say yo ma'am i'm
talking
no no no no no ma'am no ma'am i i'm
look i don't mark you out for anything
i just now talk to you i don't know you
okay well generally speaking
i i mean i put myself in in a category
with women in general that have have the
same thing where they have
mistakes that they have made taking
accountability remember not
what you think it is okay man the thing
is
thing is you say you've taken
accountability
okay and maybe
this is the most accountability you've
ever taken
but this is not accountability you're
saying that
it just happened
that is not accountability
there is not accountability man but
ma'am if your child came home if your
child came home with it
ma'am if your child came home if your
child came home with an
f in a subject
and told you it just happened
damn but i'm trying to get you to unders
that wouldn't fly that wouldn't right it
wouldn't fly
right okay so
it actually makes me really sad when i
see a lot of these girls because
gosh sometimes i just think like who who
raised you
like even the way she's not that bad
compared
to some that i've seen but even the way
sometimes they'll talk to kevin like
you know i don't know from a young age
i've always been like taught manners and
sometimes i don't think
these women have been taught manners
hold on
just a second go in your room and close
your door
yeah so
and that's all i'm trying to get ladies
like you to understand that
that when you're saying you're taking
accountability
it doesn't seem like accountability to
us
it sounds like you know um you're still
blaming
uh me or not necessarily blaming me
but it's like um
hold on guys we're having a little
technical difficulty
okay you didn't marry that you didn't
marry your other child's father
so and you said you want to get married
because you feel like you feel like it's
something you deserve
right right and and whoever i marry i
feel like that's something
what do you mean what men don't
understand is
how are you deserving of what is what do
you mean you feel like it's something
you deserve what is that
i don't understand what that means
you you don't feel like you deserve
marriage i'm talking to you man i want
you to explain what it means when you
say you deserve
marriage at almost uh
40 years old with three children
two men why do you deserve marriage
exactly so
so that goes back to what you just said
what i was just explaining to you
you put women in a category like me
myself okay i don't even know why that's
offensive
i mean less
guys will want to date you
for a lot of reasons and two kids from
or three kids from two different men is
a
pretty big reason i mean it's the same
thing for guys
like a lot of girls won't date a guy
because he has kids like it goes both
ways
we don't deserve marriage because
no well you don't deserve marriage
you haven't prioritized marriage the
decisions that
you haven't prioritized marriage and i
don't feel like that's fair
you haven't prioritized marriage so why
would i not deserve marriage
you have a prioritized marriage of those
situations my children
this is insane at 37. this woman is
insane
does that count us out yup damn
certainly does count you out
yep certainly does would it count a man
out
we're not talking about it man we're
talking about you we're not talking
about a man we're not talking about a
man we're talking about
we're not talking about a man no no no
no i'm talking about we're not talking
about him
we're not talking about a man we're
talking about you is that gonna count
them out we're not talking about a man
we're talking about you
what does he say shame insults need to
be right or
he's she's trying to compare men to
women like we're the same and we're not
you know some [ __ ] i wish was the same
for men and women but some [ __ ] just
isn't
and i'm not gonna fault the world for
the way [ __ ] just
is i don't know we're not talking about
a man we're talking about you
star you have 10 seconds to get your
[ __ ] together
got it together kevin oh good why do you
think you deserve marriage
she looks like she's about to cry with
three kids and you didn't
you didn't require marriage to have
three kids why would i not deserve them
no no no no see that's not how you
answer them that's not how you answer a
question
you answer a question you don't answer a
question with a question why would you
deserve marriage
37 with three kids from two dudes and
you didn't require marriage to make one
two or three children why would you
deserve it
because regardless of the mistakes i've
made i have grew
and i did i still feel like i deserve a
chance regardless i wasn't saying that
everyone has a chance you have a chance
by being alive
like it's about your results you haven't
said why
you you said why you want it why do you
deserve it
because i have a lot to offer kevin just
because then tell us then tell us
then tell us you said you deserve
then you start trying to put a bunch of
[ __ ] on me
i'm going to challenge your [ __ ]
why do you deserve
i deserve it because i feel like i have
a lot of value i feel like i am a good
woman
that a black man should and could have
in his life
then why didn't you feel like then why
didn't you if you
how long have you felt this way how long
have you felt this way
um maybe since i was about 30.
before 30 i don't think i was interested
in marriage kevin like i
i definitely consider myself saved um
but old is your youngest child she is
sir
how old is your youngest child after the
three k
i can see why men don't find religious
women
authentic she's eight
so before 30
you didn't deserve i wasn't interested
in it all right but see ma'am i gotta
you gotta understand something
what you did before 30 matters
right why if why does
a woman who loves her children and
raises why does a mother and father who
love their children
who raise a productive competitive
successful black man
a stable functioning son why does he
deserve
to become your step your your husband
stepfather to three children from two
dudes
and the last one you didn't even want to
marry why does that man have to take
that
instead of going to get me oh yes listen
oh yeah instead instead no no see that's
what's not you're not going to [ __ ]
do that
so you're not going to do that you're
not going to do that you're going to
answer the question the way i formulate
it
or i am it's going to be a very bad day
i get really pissed off when you ladies
try to answer questions with questions
because you're trying to be smart and
snarky then i
snap well maybe okay let me reword it
then kevin i apologize
well that's not even proper man you
don't if you're
okay that's back down do you have a job
yes what do you do for a living
i i provide home care services i have my
own home care business
i'm a personal trainer and i'm also
getting ready to graduate nursing school
december
so where in the world in business
when someone in a position of authority
a position of power
they ask you to do something or ask you
a question and you turn around and ask
them a question
to respond to the question
you don't you do that with black men
you deserve [ __ ] i do deserve it yeah
you deserve exactly what you got nothing
oh damn oh that was good
i'm being like that because i've sat
here and listened to you talk about what
you deserve
you haven't even ma'am i've put you on
so many different times and i've said
and i'm i'm sitting here advocating for
men and women and i'm sitting here
trying to understand
what i'm trying to understand okay
i'm trying to understand why somebody
needs to raise their son
to end up dealing with you why someone
would deserve
you as a daughter-in-law because i'm an
asset i'm not i'm not allowed you're not
an asset you have three children
ain't nothing about this as an asset
look at this this is more that i am a
queen
because i because i found jesus after i
had three kids
it doesn't matter it matters to men who
have a choice
it matters i had sex with a man that i
wouldn't even consider making
i wouldn't want to marry him but he was
good enough for the sex
then you think a man who's worth this
salt needs to come out and be a
stepfather to that
black women this is what i need you to
understand this is what they think your
sons deserve
this is what they think your sons
deserve
leftovers because she just decided to
get
you have not heard this woman take any
accountability
the least bit of humility she and think
about she's shown her probably on her
best behavior on this
can you imagine what happens when she
feels like she's your equal
oh look at the crazy eyes look at her
i'll make you famous oh my god okay
i do not understand where these girls
come from like sometimes i literally
think they're actors
um but this is actually a pretty
insightful live stream like
the ladies nuts um
i i'm speechless honestly but let me
know in the comments what you guys think
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell and i
will talk to you guys next time